1 les chaînes de radios des bords de
publicité pour les promotions du black
friday
avant de savoir si vous avez fait vos
courses aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
faire entendre
ce cette petite vidéo de brune poirson
c'est la secrétaire d'état à l'écologie
et alors elle le black friday c'est pas
trop son truc
regardez ces de l'aggraver c'est
vendredi noir n'ont probablement pour la
planète
parce qu'aujourd'hui on consomme 60 % de
plus de produits textiles qui a 15 ans
et on lui dit si ce monde deux fois
moins longtemps et aujourd'hui vous
allez probablement acheter des appareils
électroniques et électroménagers qui
déjà 9 est bien plus fonctionner dans
quelques années alors qu'il pourrait
encore fonctionné c'est l'obsolescence
programmée et ça en fait c'est une
double arnaque pour la planète et pour
votre porte-monnaie bernard on savait
pas que ce gouvernement était des
croissants mais apparemment non mais moi
ça me plaît bien là pour les effectifs
m'en lasse et une écologie je dirais des
qui défend je dirais un ordre des choses
par nom de revenir toujours là dessus et
non pas une écologie transhumanisme etc
enfin bon voilà qui me qui me convient
parfaitement honnêtement la la frénésie
de consommation
le fait de se sentir obligé parce que
ces soi-disant moins cher d'acheter
parce qu'on vous dit que aujourd'hui il
faut acheter alors que vous allez
acheter quelque chose dont vous n'avez
absolument pas besoin
honnêtement ça me navre absolument
honnêtement j'ai qu'un conseil à vous
donner aujourd'hui si vous voulez
acheter quelque chose
achetez vous un gilet jaune c'est clair
que j'aurais peut-être résumer à ce que
je voudrais c'est est trop belle c'est
intéressant quand même ce ce discours
est quand même assez minoritaire au sein
du gouvernement parce que on est plutôt
favorable aux échanges à la croissance
au commerce dans la république en marche
non roeckel caricature non je moi moi je
vais réagir en tant qu'éducatrice brune
poirson l'a fait en tant que
représentants de l'écologie au sein du
gouvernement
je crois je suis je pense qu'il faut
quand je vais vous gêne exprimée en
temps en tant qu'éducatrice je crois
qu'il faut qu'on enseigne à nos jeunes
générations ne pas être effectivement
les victimes de ne pas subir de ne pas
subir cette espèce de pression comme
vous disiez où on achète alors qu'on n'a
pas besoin est que et on voit bien
ensemble on sentait une forme
c'est donc je crois que on veut donner
du sens on veut remettre l'éducation au
centre et je crois disposer de son
destin c'est aussi décidé qu'on peut
faire quelque chose et plus intéressante
que d'aller comme on le voyait sur votre
image c'était très éloquent toutes ces
portes qui allait s'ouvrir
on est quelque part posséder un peu par
cette ce besoin de consommation
il ya beaucoup à dire il faut il faut
bon voilà qu'on sait c'est insupportable
enfin c'est quoi ce paternalisme laisser
les gens vivre laisser les gens
consommaient on parlait du communisme
juste avant votre anti capitalisme et et
femmes qui aiment pas identiques et six
blessées les gens échanger les acheter
ce qu'ils veulent laisser libre le black
friday sous là où il le faut c'est sur
les impôts c'est tous et il n'ya pas
d'aujourd'hui laisser les gens faire le
black friday ça montre quoi ça montre
une chose c'est que le capitalisme
réussi l'économie de marché réussie elle
a permis de dieu de démocratiser l'accès
à des ressources au plus grand nombre
toujours pour moins cher toujours
meilleure qualité faux faux faux faux
moi je crois que lorsqu'on célèbre ça et
qu'on arrête d'infantiliser les gens
s'ils veulent acheter du téléphone
portable s'ils veulent acheter des biens
de consommation c'est leur liberté et
arrêtons de d'avoir cet état jacobin qui
me dire comment va se comporter ces
idéologues qui disent non il ya ça
suffit ça suffit de laisser les gens
libres afin c'est un supporter
le capitalisme crée la richesse et seule
la création de richesse permet une
meilleure redistribution c'est les
mécanismes de marché qui permette à tous
de s'insérer dans le marché du travail
de trouver un moyen de gagner sa vie et
ça se fait que le mécanisme marché et
pas par la redistribution je tiens à ce
que vous avez fait des courses
aujourd'hui pour profiter du black
friday
n'écoutez pas du tout c'est le genre de
démarche qui m'horripile savent aussi
proche surprendra pas là dessus non faut
rappeler quand même que ça nous vient
des états unis le black friday c'est
juste le lendemain de thanksgiving donc
ça n'a rien à voir avec la tradition
française c'est un élément de
colonisation culturelle des états unis
en quelque sorte
et alors je me suis documenté j'ai lu
une étude de l'association ufc que
choisir que ses intérêts c'est justement
au black friday de l'année dernière et
paraît que l' or selon eux les
réductions en fait tu élèves à 2%
ils n'ont pas entre 20 et 50% comme on
peut le lire à l'entrée des magasins
parce qu'en réalité les magasins met sur
le devant de la scène sur le devant de
leurs comptoirs les invendus les
invendus l'épreuve les produits un peu
défectueux etc
donc c'est pas du tout l'eldorado qu'on
nous vend et que veut nous vendre ses
affaires sont un mythe juste là dessus
les invendus et tout ça c'est une
quelque chose de très écologique en fait
dire que le marché ici répond de manière
très écologique au lieu de jeter ses
invendus il est le vend moins cher c'est
c'est une des manières de l'économie de
marché de mes cd a vendu ou des idées
des idées religieuses alors donné de
travailler gratuitement si vous voulez
il n'y a pas de soucis donné ils veulent
il n'y a pas de souci allez
inscrivez-vous au pc problème la
caricature aux etats unis le black
friday a un sens car c'est le lendemain
de thanksgiving jour férié où tout est
fermé
guillaume bernard est ce que vous êtes
étonné moi je suis pour tout vous dire
par la vitesse avec laquelle cette cette
tradition américaine est arrivée en
france c'est un peu comme halloween wind
est reparti aussi vite que il y est
arrivé
ça nous a un peu libérés tant d eux oui
vous allez l'aimer
qu'est ce qui se passe vous pensez que
le les français avaient un besoin d'eux
2 mais non de promotions comme ça ou
bien grâce américaine voilà c'est que
vous voulez c'est que on laisse croire
que le consentement est toujours libre
et qu' il ne peut pas y avoir une
manipulation dire que je suis au regret
de vous dire que le le comportement de
certaines entreprises par leur capacité
de publicité notamment et bien fait que
l'on peut modifier le comportement des
gens ensuite on peut en outre d'une
certaine manière profiter de cette loi
d'imitation que le sociologue tarder
gabriel tarde a mis en avant c'est à
dire que malheureusement il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui veulent se comporter de
la même manière que d'autres tout
simplement on ne pas être marginal
j'suis pas dit que c'était mal j'ai dit
simplement que de laisser croire que le
comportement des personnes est
totalement libre que le consentement est
totalement libre systématiquement c'est
une
c'est une vue de l'esprit et qu' il y a
dans une vie de la société
autre chose que simplement la réussite
économique où la valeur des changes ce
qui moi me gêne
au delà même de cette question là on
parlait tout à l'heure de la justice de
la justice sociale c'est que nous sommes
dans une société où de plus en plus
c'est la valeur des changes et non pas
la valeur d'usagé qui prédomine dans les
rapports sociaux
donc ça c'est un me semble-t-il il ya un
vrai sujet qui est qui et où là où la
valeur
n'entendant dans la valeur dans la
valeur comment dire d'une chose il ya
une valeur objective qui est la valeur
du travail qui est la valeur des
matières qui ont permis de déterminer à
chose et puis ensuite il y à l'utilité
concept choses et pas simplement la
rencontre de l'offre et la demande et
réduire la société des gens
non c'est certainement parce que je sais
n'est certainement pas ce que j'ai dis
simplement que la valeur d'une chose ce
n'est pas uniquement la valeur d'échangé
sur que économique et ben voila je pense
à comment le fond du problème est ce que
notre société se réduit à au cours et
que est ce que notre société se réduit à
les chances de l'offre et de la demande
en échange des idées ça s'éteint c'est
un match à dix des onze échanges ya
aucun problème et c'est un marché que
j'espère pur et parfait en tout cas
c'est formidable parce que voilà c'est
le doux commerce encore que ce soir il
est pas il était assez animée et tant
mieux ça montre que même sur des sujets
aussi concret voire anecdotique que le
black friday
ils se disent des choses passionnantes
sur le plateau de point de vue merci
beaucoup à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à notre émission le
l'émission point de vue reviendra lundi
à 17h sur figaro live merci beaucoup bon
week-end
[Musique]